so for me I'd rather help the next Mark
Zuckerberg or whatever read all my books
start his business get it growing and
then say dude you help me do all this
stuff most of the wealth in the world is
created through big fast-growing
companies and it would be easier for me
to not have to have some sort of massive
education business which I don't have a
desire to build and instead just have
Goodwill which candidly I value a lot
and I think that part of it is because
of my viewpoint in the world which I
share relatively publicly that don't
think that any of us matter and then I
think when we die nothing's going to
happen and I don't think Legacy is Real
This tends to be the shovel that I want
to use to dig my own grave um and I
enjoy